today I'm going to show you how a doctor
goes shopping what you should buy in
order to stay healthy we're celebrating
10 million subscribers huge thank you to
you and obviously a huge thank you to
the team so we have to have a little
celebration and with our partner Amazon
Fresh we're gonna go shopping and I'm
going to show you everything you need to
know that a doctor looks for when they
go grocery shopping come on
huge thanks to Amazon Fresh for
sponsoring this video all right I've
already broken one of my rules and that
you're not supposed to go shopping for
food hungry please eat before you go
food shopping it's so tempting to buy a
lot of unhealthy choices just because
you're hungry in that given moment
what's cool about this Amazon Fresh
store you literally scan on your app
this in-store code that I have pulled up
on my phone walk in and then there's no
checkout you just leave
foreign
let's start the most important aisle
produce remember I always say plant
focused diet is the way to go and look
at the fresh produce like I want to I
want to go to town on these strawberries
for me my breakfast a lot of times
contain yogurt and berries why berries
rich in vitamins rich in antioxidants
not a lot of sugar if you compare it to
a pear a banana my go-to ones just for a
variety of tastes really strawberries
raspberries and one of the most
antioxidant Rich fruits out there
blueberries I see a lot of people make
mistakes when it comes to mold on their
berries if you see one Berry that's
moldy just throw that one out the rest
are still fine
see what you want to do is get frozen
berries and vegetables that you could
use in your smoothies a lot of people
think freezing berries can lower the
nutritional value but we haven't found
that to be quite true so load up on
those frozen berries
blueberries blackberries raspberries and
because they're frozen you don't even
need to add ice
I'm going to include obviously along
with some turkey some green beans this
is a great low sodium food they're rich
in vitamin K there's fiber content in
here the type of fiber that actually
helps you lower your LDL cholesterol and
if you've seen my other videos you know
that I have slightly elevated LDL
cholesterol so we're getting some green
beans today that's absolutely a must
normally I like to buy my greens loose
when you're cooking just for yourself
the proportions matter the amount you
buy matters you don't want all of it to
spoil and just be thrown out but because
we're preparing for a party I need my
greens to be pre-packaged and I really
want to focus on spinach kale arugula
Romaine as the base of my salad some
people like using iceberg lettuce while
that is rich in folate and vitamin A I
do say that the other ones tend to be a
little bit more nutritious have more
value I think you can get a mixture like
this where you get baby spinach and
arugula this has been washed it's ready
to to go it's going to make my life a
little bit more simple you can't have a
salad without tomatoes especially
beautiful tomatoes like this like this
is an epitome of a beautiful tomato
there's some doctors out there that
claim tomatoes are unhealthy or cause
problems with your gut and this is
largely untrue for the huge majority of
people this has only two grams of sugar
in half a cup despite it tasting sweet
with vitamin C potassium folate like
just so much nutrition I just want to
speaking of thanksgiving-esque foods
sweet potatoes are the way to get your
complex carbs in you just have to be
careful if you are monitoring your
caloric intake this could be a high
calorie food if you eat a lot of them
you get four grams of protein 6.6 grams
of carbs
if we're talking about Nature's
multivitamin sweet potato great great
choice my nighttime snack and I know a
lot of people laugh when uh I did the
video and I said why are you throwing
out the kiwi skin it's absolutely true
if you wash them eat it with the skin
you're going to be boosting the fiber
intake really significantly I find for
myself that kiwis helped me fall asleep
better at night there's some scientific
proof to this it's a little weak but for
me anecdotally at least it's worked
quite well and again lots of vitamins
lots of minerals
[Music]
foreign
food shopping make sure to make a list
and stick to that list number one tip I
give to parents is if you don't have
junk food in the house the kids aren't
going to eat it and Amazon Fresh cards
have a really specific indent to put
your phone in to make sure that you're
getting all the ingredients for your
list when I think about sauces I really
try and think about the nutrients that
are going to slide into my Foods so for
example if I'm going to be eating my
morning eggs and I don't want to
increase the caloric intake of my eggs
Tabasco sauce gives you a lot of flavor
without the calories literally zero
calories it's important to know that
depending on your condition you could
always go for varieties of certain foods
like for ketchup they have the no sugar
added variety if you struggle with sugar
issues perhaps if you have diabetes or
the no salt added option if you have
kidney problems or if you're struggling
with congestive heart failure while
there are some general rules about hyper
processed foods being unhealthy foods
are healthy or unhealthy depending on
your current individual life goals
medical conditions and it needs to be
individualized and tailored for you
[Music]
there's a ton of salad dressings that
are available for purchase I like to
kind of make my own with the most
magical ingredients and those are olive
oil extra virgin Greek olive oil and I
only say magic because of that cool
transition there's nothing really
magical about this it's just my
preference when it comes to oils
balsamic vinegar mix it in with the
olive oil makes perfect salad dressing
adds flavor adds kick
[Music]
if it's a sweetener and it has
carbohydrates in it it's basically the
same thing so I try and go for the
Manuka Honey version we actually use
medical grade Manuka Honey not what this
is in medicine when we're talking about
wounds that are not responding to
antibiotics we use Manuka Honey there so
I do try and put this in my tea if I'm
not feeling great but also just like a
little drizzle on my yogurt in the
morning that already has zero grams of
sugar added I add it myself with a
little bit of honey and apparently
there's a Mike's hot honey
great fibrous food here you have soluble
fiber which does tend to keep you
regular and the big surprise here six
grams of protein in just a third of a
cup fiber protein win for me now any
doctor that's going to tell you they
don't enjoy a little bit of pie every
now and then I feel like they're not
being honest with you we're celebrating
it's okay to have some pie yester
content but there's great nutrients in
here because it is a berry pie so I try
and find some kind of dessert that
always has some added nutrition to it
and berries that's a great way to boost
the nutrition for me because this is a
rare treat it's occasional it's not
going to make or break my healthy
lifestyle so I'm okay having this
especially if I have a small amount and
I don't want you deciding for your
lifestyle if you're eating completely
healthy or unhealthy based on one choice
it's about the general philosophy that
you have when it comes to food shopping
foreign
as I'm browsing through these aisles I'm
really impressed with the high quality
and the amount of selection of healthy
Whole Foods like even just walking here
and seeing this spice rack and seeing
how many options there are it's awesome
for me spices are nature's spice there's
no better way to say it because a lot of
times we say oh healthy food is boring
or doesn't taste good but that's because
we're not using spices remember a lot of
these spices are zero or low calorie
they are nutritious I even try to use
spices like cinnamon in my morning
yogurt just to add a little bit more
flavor or even in my coffee when I think
about bread I think about maximizing
nutrition from a very simple food now
this bread here has to have the first
ingredient being whole wheat not if
you're gluten-free of course and I want
the dietary fiber to be at least three
grams that that's telling me that I'm in
a good place this one's exactly three
grams because it has flax seeds and
other seeds on it you're getting a
little bit of protein as well five grams
of protein 14 grams of whole grains and
520mm grams of Omega-3 you're making a
usually non-nutritious food very
nutritious
[Music]
a lot of people like to talk about
vitamin D and its importance to health
and I agree totally but a lot of people
overdo it with Vitamin D supplements I'm
trying to find foods that have a good
amount of vitamin D content and sardines
are the way to go you know some people
make fun of me for eating sardines but
at night if I'm hungry I crack open I
can't have some not only are you getting
a serious protein boost but you're
getting Omega-3s vitamin D 70 of your
day's vitamin D in just one serving
that's three ounces of sardines
279. if you want to splurge a little bit
and go for the 329 you're going to get
sardines in olive oil which you know I
love olive oil so again very reasonable
and very doable to eat a healthy diet
it's not something I recommend but I
found that a food that allows me to
board eat and still be quite healthy and
match my caloric intake is popcorn and
this sea salt and black pepper Game
Changer literally my favorite popcorn
every friend that I let try this they
want it and it's actually hard to find
this flavor of skinny pop so I'm glad
they have it here in the Amazon Fresh
store so
I don't know I need these
don't judge me turkey a lot of people
treat it as an underrated meat you're
getting high protein content 26 grams of
protein per serving only one percent fat
it's very lean important reminder cook
your turkey to 165 degrees Fahrenheit
that's crucial to make sure that you're
killing all those pathogens that could
potentially be found in your turkey but
otherwise enjoy
this is my morning fuel before every
boxing session I'm having Greek yogurt
with granola with berries I like to get
one without the berries in it and then
add the berries myself that tends to
have less preservatives antioxidants in
the berries tend to last longer
therefore being higher amounts when I'm
actually digesting them and I
specifically go for the Stonyfield brand
there's other great Brands out there but
they have six live active cultures in
here all great species of good bacteria
that live naturally in your gut that
allow you to have a healthy microbiome
so keep those good bacteria fed so I got
my food I guess it's just the scan and
go
it is time to celebrate
okay that didn't work well
all right so we just gotta have our 10
million celebration here we got Sam The
Man Dan the Man
bear the dog and we're about to enjoy
the celebration huge thank you for 10
million Subs click here to check out the
checkup with Dr Mike it's a new podcast
with some amazing guests and don't
forget to visit Amazon Fresh locations
nationwide enjoy the affordable fresh
groceries that they have for you and if
you're a Prime member you can shop
online as always stay happy and healthy
you guys have to say it too happy and
healthy huge thanks to Amazon Fresh for
sponsoring this video